what are some of the archetypes in ye
novels not just of the protagonist which
I hear is is somehow she's the special
girl yeah for some reason and she's
different from all the others and has
some type of a special yeah or power
yeah so there are a lot of tropes that
you'll see my a for better or worse and
yes one of them is what you were just
describing which is that they're special
in some way they have some special gift
or ability or sometimes you see that
they live in a world where everyone else
has abilities and they're the ones that
don't but there is usually something
that makes them stand out in their world
in some capacity I mean you see that a
little bit more in the sci-fi fantasy
genre of yaa but yes that's a classic
trope the love triangle is another one
and you know I always think that people
say oh this is young adult I'm like yeah
but it's also like classic like
storytelling like this these stories
Romeo and Juliet you see that 400
million times Romeo and Juliet has been
told and retold and probably was taken
from something even before Shakespeare
wrote Romeo and Juliet so I think you
see these things repeat a lot Romeo and
Juliet does pop up a lot in Y a right
star-crossed lovers right Twilight is
basically Romeo and Juliet with vampires
there's a book called a worm I think
it's called warm bodies that is Romeo
and Juliet was on B and it was made into
a film as well so you see a lot of that
kind of stuff a lot of times you'll also
see so these are coming-of-age story so
usually they're being oppressed in some
way it could be by parents or adults
that rule the world it could be by some
greater antagonist but usually they're
fighting the system or they're fighting
against something about their world that
isn't fair let's talk about other
archetypes so you have sort of the jock
oh yeah the hot jock who maybe seems
like the dream guy but then you have
like the loner guy that she's not
supposed to be with because her friends
don't approve but she really likes the
frenemy the nerdy girl that's the
sidekick can we talk about some of the
archetypes
yeah that's pretty typical I mean the
nerdy girl I mean Hermione from Harry
Potter is your classic version of that
you know I think in terms of jock and
already guy yeah you're gonna definitely
still see that the Netflix show stranger
things which was really fantastic a
hundred percent does that but they do do
a few things to subvert some of that
where you know I think it's interesting
to do turns with some of those jockey
characters where maybe they see the
light come around a little you know and
those stories yeah the high school the
hierarchy of school that's gonna be very
prevalent across all these books
including the ones that aren't even in
our world like you know even things like
Harry Potter which I know skewed younger
to start by moved into why a territory
or even things like Twilight there's
always a high school element in the
hierarchy of the society so yeah you see
all of that as well you know but I think
it's kind of fun to read those things
and again they're coming from somewhere
which is the real world you know like if
we've all been to high school like I
feel like we've all had these
experiences right so it sounds like
there's either the decision to leave the
group or the decision to join the group
and and will they accept them it's
either reverse in one of those two ways
and as an adult always an oppressor no
not always usually they'll be yeah I
mean you'll usually have also characters
that are like you know nice good adult
characters or at least I always try to
write them into my book and one of the
things that I did in my my series is
that I did give point of views to adult
characters and that was actually one of
the things that also I think made the
book a challenge right off the bat to
sell even though we found a great
publisher and I did get a great book
deal out of it but in the beginning I
got feedback like you have adult points
of view in this book like how is this
why a and I'm like well the main
characters are teens but yes there are
adults that live in this world and I
wanted to show also some of that
perspective and some of the adults are
the antagonists in the case of the first
book it's the leader of the religious
contingent who kind of governs their
world gets some chapters where we get to
see sort of their thought process and
what's happening on their end of the
story
and then otherwise we're going between
Myra who is a 16 year old engineering
apprentice in the underwater world and
outer space colony where our main
character is arrow who is a 16 year old
soldier in their military society and so
the stories told back and forth between
them and then as the book series
progressives my second book comes out in
November the story opens up a lot we had
more points of view so we start to track
more characters and some of those are
adults we pick up an underwater
character who is an adult character and
he carries through so I think it's fun
to write a variety of different
perspectives but know some of the adult
characters are always you know I hope
going to be positive too you know but
you will say young adult it is mostly
focused on the kids and it is going to
be mostly focused on the team characters
you